Cómo están midiendo la participación de
Qatar como organizador Se podría decir
desde este lado del mundo que cumplió la
nación del medio oriente Pero tú que
estuviste a lo largo de estos 29 días
cómo viste el tema de organización que
al principio confrontaron algunas
dificultades pero fueron enmendando a lo
largo de estos 29 días para hoy poder
ofrecer esa gran fiesta
sin duda alguna
Qatar cumplió con la organización de un
mundial un país de tres millones de
habitantes que disputó un mundial con 64
partidos en una ciudad como doja y sus
alrededores el punto más lejano estaba
apenas a unos 50 kilómetros era un país
prácticamente con una infraestructura
nueva nos habla la gente aquí que hace
cinco años es que este país era
completamente distinto las carreteras
están nuevas el metro es nuevo y el país
cumplió el país cumplió haciendo un
mundial de fútbol recibiendo
aproximadamente un millón de personas
para Esta visita unos dos millones de
personas acudieron a las fans una un
dato que nos entregó la FIFA este
domingo en términos de organización la
verdad que salvo los algunos altercados
al comienzo entrando precisamente a esas
imágenes que vimos de los hinchas que
entraron sin boleta algunos partidos en
algunos inconvenientes con el transporte
mientras sobre todo los periodistas
comenzábamos a conocer Cómo llegar de
mejor manera a los estadios pero
lo hizo Qatar hizo su mundial una
cuestión que hay que destacar el tema de
la seguridad no hubo ningún altercado
grave a lamentar en esta copa mundo ni
por parte contra nosotros la prensa ni
contra los ni contra los hinchas una
sensación completa de seguridad un metro
que trabajaba hasta las tres de la
mañana con trenes cada tres minutos la
parte del transporte estuvo muy bien
cubierta nosotros fuimos llegamos nos
movíamos en los trenes y en los buses de
la organización y también con los
hinchas y siempre eran puntuales en la
mayoría de los casos era puntuales por
organización este país ha cumplido Con
una copa mundo hablaban ustedes antes
precisamente de lo que es el ciclo
olímpico es el siguiente objetivo de
Qatar organizar unos juegos olímpicos
esto le va a dar mucho auge es un país
Qatar que hasta el año pasado estuvo
bloqueado por sus vecinos acusado
Qatar de respaldar de respaldar los
movimientos islamistas ahora después de
haber organizado esta copa mundo ya
superadas esas discrepancias con sus
vecinos y siendo reforzado en el mundo
árabe
Qatar va a tener muchísimo para salir
adelante con esas aspiraciones de
organizar unos juegos olímpicos
entrábamos de nuevo en seguramente un
cambio de calendario para esa para esa
aspiración obviamente estoy especulando
mucho Pero obviamente si Qatar quiero
organizar unos juegos olímpicos de
verano tendría que ser de nuevo en estas
fechas porque obviamente a 50 a 55
grados que son las temperaturas que
vemos en junio Julio agosto sería algo
muy difícil hablando un poco del partido
volviendo a hablar del partido si están
conociendo poco a poco los premios que
entrega este mundial obviamente muchos
premios para el combinado campeón para
Argentina Enzo Fernández jugador al
mejor joven tiene una cláusula con el
benfica de 110 millones de euros si no
me equivoco el benfica que es un gran
negociador en el mundo del balompié
seguramente Enzo Fernández ya tenía
muchas novias antes de esta copa mundo
ahora después de ese grandísimo
rendimiento en este mundial y además
ganándose la titularidad porque no
empezó siendo inicialista va a tener
ahora muchas ofertas de grandes clubes
de otros grandes clubes porque también
lo es otro premio que ya se dio a
conocer el premio al mejor portero
Adivinen para quién es para Emiliano
Martínez el Diego Martínez un Portero
que juega desde hace diez años en
Inglaterra comenzó o más bien llegó a
jugar en la cuarta división en la tierra
llegó al Arsenal cuenta él lo ha contado
mucho esta semana presionado porque dice
él su papá no tenía para pagar las
facturas Así que decidió mudarse a
Inglaterra siendo muy joven y ahí empezó
en el Arsenal justo antes de la Copa
América cuenta Emiliano que no tenía
titularidad y que recibió con mucho
cariño que Leonel escalonia haya
apostado por él y él a ver cumplido
siempre además siempre de la misma
manera siendo el rey de los penaltis hoy
ata